bought eight properties in a recession
2010 2011 and became financially free
quite young I achieved my goal and then
in success what do you really learn
nothing you learn everything in Failure
you've doubled your profit you were
making four or five grand now you're
making closer to 10 grand the way you
make your first million will be
different to the way you make your next
10 million which will be different to
the way you makes your next 100 million
it stops becoming about you and your
journey and your Financial Freedom it
becomes about okay what's best for my
girls the moment you think that you know
it all and you're not growing and
evolving you're shrinking you're gonna
get a ton of no's the idea is that you
just break through those nodes keep
plugging through and eventually you get
through
doc thanks for coming to my house thanks
for inviting me I wanted to talk about
property you're a property millionaire
you're also a doctor and you've got a
nice portfolio which you've recently
over the last few months restructured
and you've increased the the profits
quite a lot so why don't you just talk
to me a bit about why property in the
first place why as a doctor and a lot of
doctors I've noticed are also do
property part-time but why did you start
buying houses oh okay the honest answer
to that actually not many people know
about but um I'll give it to you Samuel
because when I was a junior doctor being
a junior doctor is incredibly tough what
you hear in the media plus some do
nights evenings weekends 12 hour shifts
and if I'm being totally honest I was
failing totally and utterly failing as I
didn't enjoy the job completely
different to medical school it's not fun
anymore you're a glorified pencil
pushing secretary my clinical supervisor
kind of pulled me up and said look
you're not performing uh this isn't good
enough I've got it was career scare
because I've invested so much time
energy and effort into becoming a doctor
and I just was like oh crap
um you know I need a plan B and so that
really was my fuel on like being a
doctor is great it's my passion I love
it
um great privilege but I definitely
needed a plan B Because at in that
moment when I was 23 years old you know
what do you know at 23 I felt like oh my
God I'm feeling insecure and vulnerable
in my career I need a plan B and that
really propelled me to cake property I
came from a background of Builders
plumbers electricians so I thought put
two and two together I was a junior
doctor Milton Keynes that let me just
use my family setup and build a
portfolio in Milton Keynes so it wasn't
that you wanted to not be a doctor it
was more that you wanted to have the
security to know that if ever anything
happened with your career you're okay
absolutely yeah it was Financial Freedom
was the the goal you know I wanted that
time Choice freedom to do what I wanted
to do how I wanted to do it with whoever
I wanted to do it with did you buy your
first property the traditional route did
you just save up and put money down to
deposit yeah for my salary savings like
you pay around from the age of 13 all of
that sort of grinding hard work you know
I used to care I used to do paint jobs
so all of that bought my first property
borrowed money for my second investment
property with the bank of mum and dad
and yet built my portfolio through brrr
strategy back then it wasn't called BR
what we were doing is buying dumps
doing them up having a go making them as
pretty as possible fingers crossed
hoping that the valuation officer in six
months will like you know say oh yeah
it's significant and then remortgaging
and and releasing the equity and just
recycling that and you've got an
impressive portfolio you you know you
own what is it about 3.6 million pounds
yeah yeah definitely and of course
you've got your mortgage as well but
you've got your Equity what what was it
that you learned then so when we started
talking what was it that made you kind
of register for the training and come to
my programs when you were already in
property at a nice portfolio already
making sort of four or five grand a
month profit in a job that you enjoy as
a doctor what was the pull fair question
and so I think with me I got success
quite young so I became financially free
so 23 when when the crap happened with
being a junior doctor and career being
unquestion and then I put all my time
energy enough I really went into it full
swing of property and about eight
properties
um in a recession 2010 2011 and became
financially free quite young so 25 26
and then I kind of just hovered in this
success I lived in a little tiny flat so
if I'm being financially free as it
wasn't that impressive but like I
achieved my goal and then in success
what do you really learn nothing you
learn everything in failure and
adversity and so I kind of just fizzled
out I kind of neglected my portfolio let
it kind of do its thing allow the
management company estate agents to kind
of just take it from here and and they
made a bit of a mess out of things and
not you know improve the rents
accordingly so again I found myself in a
bit of a slump with tax changes
happening and and property sort of
catching up with me so no longer am I
you know saying oh yeah my poor I can
lean on my portfolio for holidays this
year no no no no you know tax changes
happen government Law changes happened
and actually that all caught up with me
and I thought hang on a minute this
isn't what I signed up for and then you
know the other bits are you know bought
an overpriced house in London uh and
then you can become un financially free
quite quickly if you know what I mean
you know your liabilities go up and that
that'll do it so I was in a bit of a
place so I had a bit of a choice do I
have a crack at it again myself and you
know try and build up the portfolio
or do I do this thing properly join a
proper Academy proper mentors proper
training learn things I was out of touch
you know like I said I was successful
when I was 23 24 but I reflect back and
I think each and every property I bought
was very different to the previous one
and I was making mistakes and those
mistakes cost money and yes I I was
successful you can call it in terms of
building a portfolio but I probably made
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of pounds of mistakes yeah so
I figured let me do this properly let me
join a proper course with you I was
watching your YouTube videos
and I thought yeah I'm going to surround
myself with the right people go to the
right training get the right education
and
you know have the mentorship yeah that
comes with your Academy I think that's
so important for someone like me I don't
care where you are who you are if you're
wanting to achieve anything significant
in Life or property or otherwise it's
gonna take six months to ten years no
matter what you want to do in that six
months to ten years or what you know
whatever your goal is you're going to
come across challenges you're going to
come across problems in that scenario
when you're jumping through a hoop do
you want to have a go yourself and and
just try and make the best decision with
what you've got or do you want to speak
to a mentor who's experience and
specialize and that's the beauty of your
Academy you know you you've got that to
hand it makes sense it makes sense and
also sometimes people say you know a lot
of doctors a lot I've not really got the
time to be part of the academy and it's
like if you're going to do property it's
going to save you time because the
amount you know you're gonna you're
gonna be able to find the Nifty tricks
of the trade so so it makes sense so
what's changed then over the last sort
of I don't have many months ago was when
you joined the academy he was coming up
to a year is it yeah he's coming up to I
joined in September so yeah six seven
months I've enjoyed it immensely I've
done all the training I love that kind
of thing going to courses and listening
to you and you've got and if you if you
allow me to pay you a compliment you've
got this amazing gift of condensing
complex things into a simple
understandable format I can listen to
you all day long and I I memorize some
of the stuff that you say is because
you've done that being there got the
t-shirt and you're you're sort of like
when you go speak to an accountant or a
lawyer they'll give you jargon right
yeah
deliberately I think so but it is
because if an accountant makes it really
simple then they almost feel like
they're making themselves replaceable or
or they'll think oh if they make it
sound complicated oh just I'll pay you
to sort it you know I think they make a
same with lawyers yeah deliberately I
think lawyers are a bit more yeah high
level would you but you know what I do I
don't know if you already knew this I
might have told you this before but if I
want to learn something what I do
because people say to me how do you know
like when you get all the information
from let's say I want to learn about
commercial valuations we discussed that
last week yes and I explained it in
about five minutes and suddenly oh it's
really easy you can easily work out the
commercial valuation I had to sit with a
commercial valuer
for about 10 hours straight
paying them that hourly rate of 350
pounds an hour so not only is it costing
me like four grand but it's also costing
me 10 hours of brain power and time like
below the hell of a stone with not just
any commercial valuer someone that I
think is going to be the best teacher
the most competent and then after like
10 hours I'm fine no right I fully get
what I came for now thank you Cheerio
pay on that bill and then I'll explain
it to people like yourself
in five minutes and by the way we
absolutely benefit from that big time I
mean we're just touching on the acpp
which is the coaching two-day course
that you provide once you've done all
the training and that's where all the
magic happens I can't tell you how much
I loved going to those two days I'm so
glad man it's not just when you pick
apart everyone's business plans and
really give you give people bespoke
advice based on your experience but it's
just when you listen to other people
yeah and it's so fascinating for me how
everyone is in a complete different
scenario like not one not two people
were in the same spot yeah everyone was
doing different things and you can learn
so much from listening to other people's
Stories the acpp is where you need to
aim for as an academy member do all your
training learn and I just want to say
this bit because I think this is
important nothing worth having comes
easy this is the misconception I think
in today's society I hope and I don't
want to be come across patronizing or
anything like that but really and truly
if you want to achieve anything in
property
give it the respect it deserves join an
academy
do some proper training talk to people
who are experienced you know rub
shoulders with mentors learn study grow
evolve in an environment that is
conducive to that and then you'll find
your success I always use the analogy of
I want to improve my health and you know
I've got two kids and I've got great
motivation to do that and I've been
going regularly for the last three
months but I don't have a six-pack and
the idea that you can get things quickly
and do I'm against that I think you know
you've got to
give it the time give it the energy give
it the work consistency that it's that
it's due I totally agree I always say
this is all on the masterminds and this
is something that you probably say in
property you're always going to have
challenges you're never going to get to
the point where you got I've cracked it
because the first challenge might be oh
I'm struggling with my business plan
then it might be I'm struggling to find
a deal that is I found a deal and I'm
struggling to get a mortgage now I've
got a deal but I've got a bad tenant now
everything's perfect and I'm making
millions of pounds now I've got to find
a way to shrink my tax bill there's
always going to be something if you go
in knowing that and knowing there's
going to be challenges I think it makes
it um much easier how does that fit your
record with me doing like Financial
Freedom challenges where I'm showing how
doable how accessible it is yeah because
some critics might say I make it look
too easy
but then at the same time I'm trying to
make it really simple so that people get
it and can see how doable it is what do
you think about that well that's a
really really fair but I could see it
from both sides I
I think you're in a very difficult
position uh I admire your your role on
the one hand you're balancing to try and
make this knowledge accessible to those
who don't have it and you want to really
instill learning and growth in those
people who need it on the other hand you
want to make it as realistic as possible
and there is that balance that you have
to come up with now don't envy that
position what I want to say the first
point is that I admire someone like
yourself I do know a fair number of
millionaires and a lot of them hide away
yeah
some of them say oh I'd love to help out
and you know just you get involved with
teaching and training and that sort of
thing but you have created a
comprehensive well thought out Academy
you've created this platform where
people will come to learn grow evolve I
don't necessarily you say think that
you're saying that oh watch this YouTube
video and you'll be a millionaire you're
saying look this is part of it it can be
easy it can be accessible but also join
my Academy and learn properly learn the
skills that you need spend time with the
people that you need to spend time grow
learn evolve that way yeah so I don't
think your message is that simple you're
saying this is you can be done anyone
can do it but give it the time energy
and effort it's just you yeah and also
when is me doing it I'm very experienced
it's like you know David Beckham makes
it easy to bend the ball yes all I'm
doing in this and isn't it amazing but
it's taken me 15 years of hard work to
get to where I'm at it doesn't come easy
it does and I even today work extremely
hard well if you've done in your
portfolio then because you've um and
that's why I invited to come on the show
yeah because you've doubled your profits
you were making four or five grand now
you're making closer than 10 grand in
your property income how have you done
that I've equipped myself with knowledge
uh which is being provided by your
Academy I've learned the different
strategies
um and I've understood what is possible
and you know you don't know what you
don't know blind spots isn't it and I
had massive amounts of those and so when
I realized actually these properties
could be achieving a lot more and you
know I've worked alongside Assisted
Living companies yeah and I've turned my
property some of them into renting them
out to people with assisted living in
companies and organizations no strategy
there it is and uh yeah so I've learned
I've grown I've evolved I've overcome
some problems uh that I've been
experiencing and yeah and I've just
tidied up my portfolio massively I've
joined with my close friend and cousin
Raj and he's another you know part of my
Armory in a way because he's he's
brilliant he's experiencing property
it's quantity surveyor by trade and so
we bounce off each other really well our
skill sets are slightly different yeah I
feel like with his help with your help
with the academy you know the world's my
oyster again I can I can you know what
we're looking at now is brrr projects
and blocks of essays to boost cash flow
in terms of your five C's you know I
love that by the way cash control cash
flow capital and then charity yeah I'm
at the last two cities you know I'm
trying to build my capital and uh and
and also the the doctoring side of
things is my passion and that's my
charity so yeah I've just loved this
year I loved learning about property or
over again and getting my mind up to the
knowledge standard yeah and it's
interesting that you've managed to
increase your profit so much by just
paying attention to your portfolio and
and restructuring things and fixing
things because it's almost like there's
no point trying to grow you would have
been wasting your time buying loads more
houses before you've restructured the
properties that you've got talk to me
about the tax things because I know you
I think you decided against trying to
sell your personal properties to a to a
company what were the pros and cons of
that because that's a lot of well a lot
of people have that issue a lot of
people have that issue and just to be
clear we're talking about owning
property per in your own personal name
yeah it's a massive problem for massive
lots of landlords and with the mortgage
relief now is essentially pizzling out
with section 24 landlords can no longer
claim against their mortgage relief and
so lots of landlords are trying to
figure out you know creative ways of
overcoming this problem and I'm in that
same boat right it's a significant
problem I'm looking at you know ways of
trying to navigate through it
um I haven't quite cracked it yet and
it's not easy I didn't bother I just
left it I just thought moving forward I
want to do it differently but from the
problems I've currently got there are
ways you can transfer your personal
portfolio to a company but is it worth
the expense and for me that expense
comes to close to 300 Grand so I have to
think well am I going to get my return
on investment than that it will take me
about eight years to recoup that money
is going to work with capital gains tax
stamp Duty exactly that and legal fees
yeah exactly that so it's so I've got to
weigh it up and I know in the ACP you
know that this is the beauty of that so
we went into this in detail and you said
look based on everything sell up bit by
bit and maybe move into something else
maybe don't mind quoting you you said
the way you make your first million will
be different to the way you make your
next 10 million which will be different
to the way he makes your next 100
million and so I think I'm at that stage
where I've done well great but now I
need to think and rethink about how I do
things going forward I haven't made my
mind up but I'm leaning towards what
you've advised which is sell up bit by
bit then go into something completely
different and we were looking at
commercial property look at that
commercial property which is quite
exciting yes a bit of a crash commercial
crash course yes we did yeah and you're
talking about other sort of strategies
and Platforms in which like you know
pensions and sips and all of that sort
of thing so I've got to do much more
learning and growing to go to that level
were you in the right place I'm in the
right place what is it that drives you
because you've got so much energy and so
much passion even at the events you know
you work really hard as a doctor but at
the events you've got so much energy and
even now you can just tell that you're a
guy that loves life what is it that gets
you up out of bed in the morning I mean
that's such a massive compliment from
someone like yourself your energy is
unrivaled
you know there's two a thousand or plus
people in in a room and you're bringing
it yeah and that is admirable I love
appreciate it man my energy easy that's
an easy question for me I've got two
girls Sia Nisha age three and four and
they are my reason I will not stop I
will keep improving I'll keep learning
I'll keep growing and you know it wasn't
until they came along until they kind of
like shook out of it because I was just
fiddling out in property if I'm being on
honest before I joined the academy my
girls are my reason you know I won't
fizzle out anymore I will keep growing
keep keep going because of them just
about the Legacy absolutely and that's
why you enjoyed the talk about trusts
and inheritance tax so much yeah
yeah they are important it stops
becoming about you and your journey and
your Financial Freedom it becomes about
okay what's best for my girls you know
how can I maximize things for them and
give them the best future possible yeah
that's why I'm here you know how do you
juggle time management then because I
imagine it's quite a high pressure job
being a doctor life and death sometimes
on on the line
um how do you juggle family kids being a
doctor and also having a multi-million
pound property portfolio look it's not
easy I'd love to ask you that same
question as well because you do it in
Spades probably more than me but you
know being a doctor is is a tough crack
I don't think you can do it
half-heartedly I certainly don't I give
it the time energy and effort it
deserves I love being a doctor you've
got to find the right balance you know
and you've got to put things into your
life that that allow you to decompress
so for me it's gym I go three times a
week I've got a great wife Marla she's
much brighter well much more well
balanced and well-rounded than I am and
so she all just quite oftenly give me
some Choice words to just reject things
and I think you need those pit stops in
your life I'm blessed I've got my girls
they I just look at them and I get
energy
um and so you know things are really
unprivileged now and you know I wasn't
growing up the complete opposite my mum
and dad their work in class you can say
that but my mum to be precise she was a
carer her dad's a builder so I didn't
have that silver spoon growing up and it
doesn't take long for me to just like
reflect back growing up and how tough
things were is to kind of find comfort
and solace in that done really well can
be really proud of my achievements
balancing things are always going to be
tough my practice always comes about my
GP practice always comes above property
so I do give it the time energy and
effort as you know in business and in
and in life and in work you don't stop
you work until you're eight PMS your
nine PMS your 10 PMS as long as you have
regular breaks you have you surround
yourself with the right people you're
humble enough to realize that actually
you don't know everything
put yourself in the right environment
the academy give yourself the best
chance everyone gets stressed including
myself I go to the gym to you know
today's my gym day so I'll go and unwind
and you know I've joined David Lloyd so
there's a spa there yeah and I
noticeably feel different I feel
decompressed at the end of that you know
we're all humans above any role that we
have we're all humans I can cry when
I've had a tough week I can even cry
when I'm hungry you know with the human
beings first of all we've got to look
after ourselves only then we can look
after our family and our jobs and so on
I love that and I love the consistency
as well because it will be so easy to
think obviously you've got your family
first then you practice as a doctor and
really properties kind of last but it'll
be really easy to just completely
neglect it but just by being disciplined
and spending you know having those three
sessions a week at the gym I mean
disciplined with you or however many
hours of solid you put aside for your
property business yeah it's it's
important yeah and I think one of the
reasons that you're so successful is
you're also
um you're very coachable because it'll
be very it's very easy for someone who's
been in the game since 2011. yeah who
owns you know lots and lots of property
he's got millions of pound worth of
portfolio to sort of think oh I've been
there and I've done it and I know it all
but actually you're saying no things
have changed rules and regulations I
want to grow I want to upscale I'm gonna
remain coachable the moment you think
that you know it all and you're not
growing and evolving you're shrinking
couldn't agree more that is great advice
for anyone trying to achieve anything
you've got to put regular time energy
and effort and consistent work into
anything that you want to achieve and I
think there is another thing to be said
about having drive or passion whatever
it is you need that something to ensure
that you keep going despite knocks I'm
not told many people this story probably
because I was too embarrassed but you
know I'm happy to say it now in terms of
how I got into medical school so I
applied to four universities like
everyone I got rejected from all four
wow yeah yeah so two of the universities
Manchester and Birmingham they didn't
even give me an interview
the other two Queen Mary's and Kings I
did go for an interview but completely
fumbled it and I didn't come from a
background of doctors and I could just
ask my cousin to coach me or something
like that which is often the case with
doctors you know they they do have moms
and dads who are doctors who can give
them some regular coaching and so on and
so forth so I wasn't polished at all I
was very raw I had ambition I needed to
kind of I was I was almost desperate to
get out the situation that I was in
working class family and tough
upbringing I completely fumbled the
interview so I I was without any offers
in medical school despite getting no
offers in medical school I was I was
just committed almost desperate or
you know really ambitious to try and
make something of my life that I
quite
desperately called all the universities
and a lot of them laughed me off the
phone Sam you can imagine what you're
calling if we've got any spare places
for medical school and I said yeah
that's why I'm calling
um do you and they're like no of course
not boom and I just kept on doing that
despite people laughing and this is what
I'm saying you've got to be able to push
through the failures and so I eventually
after like calling 15 odd universities
came across one university called Keel
University they did have a couple of
places available in in their medical
school and I said well okay how do I get
access to these two places and then goes
well you've got to come for an interview
there's been quite a lot of demand
there's lots of people coming but if
you're happy to come up we'll interview
you right so I you know pack an
overnight bag stay the night at Keel
medical school
um and have the interview the next day
and I just break down in the interview
completely lose all sense of self and
just tell them about how much this would
mean to me in my life I just
passionately describe how important this
place at Medical School would mean for
me the next day I get a phone call from
the lady and she says oh look I'm really
sorry I've been calling lots of people
and I've been telling them they've only
been two places and we had 50 applicants
instead of 40 that we thought so I'm
really sorry to tell you that you've got
in
and that was my Eureka moment I mean
that that is the moment where I thought
oh my God I finally made it the reason
why I'm telling you this story is that
there was virtually no chance of me
going to medical school that that story
of calling universities up to seeing
they've got places is a bit of a joke
thing to do especially when we're
talking about medical school but it just
goes to show that if you keep persisting
keep trying and I think that's what
property is about you're going to get a
ton of no's and the idea is that you
just break through those no's keep
plugging through and eventually you'll
get lucky and yeah you get through well
you'll get lucky because you get the
system that's it yeah wow well on that
note I mean that's been an awesome
interview so much value in it and you're
such a top guy and I've loved working
with you bro thank you thank you for
everything that you do and I know
firsthand how easy it is for you to make
you know 10 grand I've seen you deal
selling you know in front of hundreds of
people you can make 10 grand in 10
minutes but instead you decide to make a
well thought out Academy where people
can come learn grow evolve and I think
that's a wonderful thing on a personal
level I think credit to you really I
appreciate people like you and I'm a
huge fan
thank you brother thank you
foreign
[Music]